hello I'm Gavin I'm done and we are the
slow mo guys we always have been
deep down I'd say I saw a high-speed
flash image online of a drill spinning
pain in all directions look really cool
and being high speed flash I imagine
there was no video to go alongside it so
we're gonna shoot the slow-mo video
version of the drills what ping paint in
the air I've got big drill bit here yeah
six different colors of paint sort of
nice bright nice gradient there yeah
gonna glob it all over the drill bit
spin it round and make a nice pattern so
gonna poke it through like a white board
and then see what the pattern looks like
I've got to make some nice art lovely
yeah
alright what's that a little process
here okay the first thing I'm going to
do is drill a hole through this this
board which we can then as eight bucks
down the drain just make another finger
yeah that's good
yeah really saturate the drill go wow
I'm really cool hahaha no Dawson I sniff
it oh I don't think I didn't do better
drove it's completely loose I looked
wicked bugs cool haha you go for the try
these holidays covered in paint for a
Ford and no I Bo's done great too
well I think that like damn to
magnificent to be honest look at that it
does look really cool some proper our
trailer damien hirst watch out yeah I
think we should sign it and yeah didn't
I do first bid 20 P yeah you want to do
it yeah you hold this mm a bit like now
you can do get Duncan there yep but Dan
oh I need more paint
oh god this isn't my actual signature by
the way in case you're watching it
Oh Bob sketch the whole video that
getting paint on me you do that
absolutely
Ronald get it off now
so thank you very much for watching that
video don't eat the paint sorry
so I wants to taste that so that the
corner wide yeah
please follow us on Twitter if you would
like subscribe to the channel but any
share even buy a shirt they're lovely
and as always Dan will buy you a drink
if he sees you wearing the shirt it's in
his contract he has to do it legally
it's true
notice ya bro
love your genuine annoyance something
French you can leave that in yeah